[Applause]
thanks to skillshare for helping support
this episode
hey crazies i absolutely love polarizing
filters
they're a common feature in sunglasses
to help reduce glare they're used in
photography for a similar reason
but my favorite polarizer effects happen
when you have more than one
how they filter light depends on their
orientation this allows us to see stress
patterns in just about anything
transparent including your car window
and how that works is surprisingly
straightforward
[Music]
light is literally all we can see it's
how our vision works
light enters our eyes and our brain
parses out the information
direction gives us a sense of the shapes
and sizes of objects
the wavelength of the light is
interpreted as color well at least for
the tiny portion of the spectrum we can
actually see
but light has other properties that we
can't see
at least not without a little help
that's where a pair of polarized
sunglasses can come in handy
polarization is just the orientation of
a light wave it's something we can't
normally see
this is a scientific tool that allows
your brain to see polarization
these lenses interact with the
polarization of light which changes how
we see the world and we can take
advantage of that to see some really
cool stuff
stuff like this
beautiful isn't it
what is that a stress pattern
it's telling you something about the
internal structure of a ruler
lots of objects have internal stresses
based on how they're made polarizing
filters also known as polarizers lets
you see a remnant of that process
you can tell the plastic in this ruler
cooled inward from the edges forming
stress rings
this wicked cool effect is called
photoelasticity
but just having a pair of polarized
sunglasses isn't quite enough to see it
the light needs to be uniformly
polarized first and unfortunately for us
most light is randomly polarized
that means all the waves from the light
source are randomly oriented we need
them to look like this first uniformly
oriented
that's why we need a second filter
one filter polarizes the light a second
filter lets you see that orientation
as we turn the second filter the light
gets dimmer eventually it'll be oriented
perpendicular to the first and no light
survives it goes black
of course you probably don't have a big
bag of polarizers laying around but you
do have the lcd screen you're watching
this video on
the screen in your phone or connected to
your computer already has a polarizing
filter in it just open an empty canvas
and microsoft paint or whatever and
you've got yourself a source of
uniformly polarized white light
now all you need is a pair of polarized
sunglasses and you're good to go
just rotate the sunglasses in front of
the screen and you'll see it go dark
just like with my square filter i have
one of these taped to my phone camera so
what you're about to see will be as if
you're wearing the glasses
so we've got one polarizing filter in
the computer screen and one polarizing
filter attached to my camera the screen
looks a little dark because the filters
are perpendicular to each other or at
least close but watch what happens when
i bring in the clear plastic ruler bam
stress pattern
but if the filters are perpendicular how
does any light get through the plastic
material rotates the light
yes it's true that two polarizers
oriented at 90 degrees should block all
light it's not perfect because the
effect is wavelength dependent but
that's a whole other conversation
the first one makes the light uniformly
polarized and the second one will block
any light perpendicular to its own axis
but all bets are off when you stick
something in between
this ruler rotates the light wave as it
passes through by the time the light
gets to the second polarizer it's not
perpendicular anymore
the effect happens with reflection too
here's a picture of my iris with and
without polarization it's taken with my
phone camera the polarizer square is
covering both the lens and the flash you
can see it with any iris but it's more
dramatic with blue and green eyes
anyway
patterns like this might help you notice
stuff you missed with your own eyes the
pattern in this protractor seems to be
radiating from an off-center point on
the edge a closer look reveals a tiny
chip in the plastic
something similar happens with my
triangle ruler with the polarizers you
can see a fine crack in the plastic it's
obvious the stress has been released at
that point which deformed the overall
pattern quite a bit due to the
redistribution of internal forces
engineers do this all the time to test
parts
of course if the rotation of that light
happened uniformly the ruler would be
solid white
that's not what happened though there's
a clear rainbow effect
the rotation the light experiences
doesn't just depend on the stress of the
material but also the wavelength of
light
you can actually see where the forces
are greatest within the plastic the same
thing happens inside your car windows
these spots are stress points within the
glass
points of maximum internal force
see there are two basic ways to make
glass annealing and tempering annealing
is pretty straightforward the glass is
molded and then allowed to cool
gradually
that means there are no particular
places within the glass where you see an
excess of stress
front wheel front wheel shields
[Laughter]
front wheels
i can do this
the front windshields of vehicles are
made with annealed glass and so are the
windows in your home
tempered glass is different
the glass is still molded but it's
cooled off quickly from the outside
which distributes the internal forces
unevenly we end up with high tension in
some places and high compression in
others
why would anyone do that
safety safety safety
if you ever end up with your car in a
body of water you're going to be happy
with this design
water exerts a thousand times the
pressure of air so you won't be able to
open your car door to escape the only
way out is if you can safely break your
windows
but here's what annealed glass looks
like when you break it you end up with a
few large and very sharp pieces of glass
the water would have thrown several of
those at you as it poured in and
climbing out over any pieces that stayed
attached to the door would be dangerous
tempered glass on the other hand
i've got to remember to stop saying that
the forces on the outside make it
incredibly strong to protect you from
things like rocks it's very difficult to
break as you can see from my first few
attempts there are special hammers with
sharp tips that are supposed to help but
i found for my experiment that they're
basically useless on tempered glass
there's just not enough weight behind
them don't waste your money the exterior
strength can be overcome though and when
it is the interior forces are ready to
tear the glass to shreds it just wants
an excuse
you'll need an actual hammer with some
weight to the head but apparently even
that's not enough
if you hit the glass at or near the
corner its weakest point then and only
then will the glass break
when that happens the internal stresses
will shatter it into a bunch of tiny
pieces here's an up close look it's
completely destroyed
that means if you ever find yourself in
that underwater situation there won't be
any large pieces of glass being thrown
at you there's no more window the water
pours in quickly and you can climb out
no problem
not that i anticipate ever being in that
situation but better safe than sorry
anyway superman ultimate point if you
have a pair of polarized sunglasses then
you have a powerful scientific tool
they let you see the orientation of
light a property otherwise invisible to
us with that new power and an lcd screen
you can peer into the internal structure
of a material you can see where it's
already under stress even before you do
anything to it
think about that the next time you see
spots in your car window though you may
be too busy wondering how i made my 3d
animations
look no further than after effects which
you could learn how to use by joining
skillshare skillshare is an online
learning community with thousands of
classes for anyone who wants to explore
their creativity or learn new skills
when it comes to 3d animation you don't
always need fancy modeling software
sometimes after effects will do
if you're unfamiliar i would recommend
checking out the ultimate guide to 3d in
adobe after effects by jake bartlett
first he'll walk you through how 3d
cameras and lighting work
later in the class you'll learn how to
give your objects depth
usually that's good enough for me
but if you need to make spheres or
texture surfaces you'll want to work
with something like cinema 4d or blender
both of which skillshare has plenty of
classes on if animation isn't your thing
though they have other classes that
might match your interests
if this sounds like a service you might
be interested in check out skillshare
the first 1000 people to use my special
link will get a one month free trial it
also let skillshare know you heard about
them from me which helps out the channel
so are you gonna try the stress patterns
experiment yourself
let us know how it goes in the comments
thanks for liking and sharing this video
a special thanks goes out to my patreon
patrons and youtube members like kevin
flanigan our new einsteinium level
supporter thanks kevin don't forget to
subscribe if you'd like to keep up with
us and until next time remember it's
okay to be a little
crazy i appreciate all the
recommendations that people left in the
comments of the last video
everyone learns a little differently so
having a large collection of sources in
one place can be super helpful thanks to
all the commenters and thanks to
everyone for watching